c'est un nouveau traité de paix
trouvaient dans la région la plus
instable du globe
un accord présenté comme historique
entre les émirats arabes unis et israël
sous la houlette des états unis énorme
percée aujourd'hui à l'accord de paix
historique entre nos deux grands amis
israël et les émirats arabes unis une
percée spectaculaire et historique selon
le président américain qui se félicite
d'avoir fait avancer les relations dans
la région entre deux de ses alliés un
accord unique d'après lui comme on n'a
pas vu depuis l'accord entre la jordanie
et l'état hébreu 7 en 1994 les émirats
arabes unis deviennent de 3e états
arabes à normaliser ses relations avec
israël et donc à reconnaître sa
légitimité
l'egypte ayant franchi le pas la
première c'était en 1979 accords de paix
coopération bilatérale au simple
normalisation des relations
dans cette poudrière historique les mots
ont leur importance
alors que donald trump se targue d'avoir
trouvé un accord de paix la maison
blanche elle préfère parler d'une
normalisation complète des relations
entre l'état hébreu et les émirats
arabes unis au moyen orient mêmes
déséquilibres alors que benyamin
nétanyahou évoque un jour historique
l'homme ford abu dhabi évoque lui une
coopération et une feuille de route vers
l'établissement d'une relation
bilatérale
un jour historique plus intriguant
encore alors qu israël évoque un report
de l'annexion de pans entiers de la
cisjordanie
abu dhabi parle d'un renoncement au
projet mais alors à qui profite vraiment
cet autoproclamé prouesses diplomatiques
qui n'a pas manqué de faire réagir le
monde entier les palestiniens sont ils
les heureux perdants de cet accord il
suffit de se pencher un peu sur le
communiqué de la maison blanche pour
observer la liste des points d'accord
trouvé entre les deux pays et qui
pourrait selon ses auteurs de fer
qu'améliorer la situation dans la région
investissement tourisme vols directs
sécurité télécommunications santé
culture ou encore environnement dans ce
communiqué est l'impasse semble avoir
été fait sur un point essentiel moteur
des relations jusqu'à la discrète entre
les deux alliés des etats unis à savoir
l'existence d'un ennemi commun qui n'est
autre que l'iran la montée en puissance
supposée de la république islamique
d'iran inquiète salle
la première armée de la région et son
tout nouveau partenaire arabe officielle
crainte à laquelle s'ajoutent les
supputations sur les capacités
nucléaires des iraniens et leur
influence toujours importante en syrie
au yémen ou encore en irak
mais alors qu'en est il réellement du
sort des palestiniens dans ce mariage
les émirats ne souhaite pas voir la
question palestinienne contrarier la
normalisation de leurs relations avec
israël et s'attire les foudres de leurs
voisins et partenaires arabes des
manoeuvres en tout cas transparente pour
les palestiniens israël a été récompensé
pour ne pas avoir déclaré ouvertement ce
qu'il faisait à la palestine de manière
illégale et persistante depuis le début
de l'occupation
les émirats arabes unis ont révélé au
grand jour leur relation secrète et leur
normalisation avec israël
cet accord qui devrait être signé dans
les prochains jours à washington ne
semble pas sans conséquence pour
l'avenir de la région
pour donald trump en chute libre dans
les sondages à moins de trois mois de
l'élection présidentielle américaine
cela semble surtout être l'occasion de
mettre en avant ses talents
diplomatiques
plutôt étonnant dans la bouche d'un
homme qui en déplaçant son ambassade à
jérusalem puis reconnaissant l'annexion
par israël du plateau du golan avait
jusqu'ici plutôt contribué
ravivé les tensions dans la région